good morning welcome to Google i/o 2015
I'm excited to share a preview of the
new M release of Android what app
permissions we're giving users
meaningful choice and control over the
data they care about you don't have to
agree to permissions that don't make
sense to you with Android pay users can
simply and safely use their Android
phone to pay in stores you can use your
fingerprint to authorize Android pay
transactions today we're happy to
announce that there are already more
than 4,000 apps built specifically for
Android wear each one is a powerful
example of what's possible on a wearable
device today we're announcing project
brillo which is the underlying operating
system for the Internet of Things these
is the communications layer by which the
Internet of Things can actually talk to
each other
you need a common language so that
devices can not only talk to each other
and to the cloud and to your phone we're
working on a new capability to assist
you in the moment right when you need it
wherever you are on the phone we're
calling it now on tap so here you see an
email from my friend Allie about
catching a movie I want to find out more
all I have to do is a simple tap and
hold on the home button Google now
brings me information about tomorrow
night I'm thrilled to be here to
introduce a brand new product Google
photos I can view my memories across
days but with a simple pinch across
months and again across years you can
now back up and store unlimited
high-quality photos and videos for free
a year ago on this very stage we
introduced Google cardboard our goal
with cardboard was to make virtual
reality available to everyone so today
we'd like to preview something we call
jump jump enables any creator to capture
the world in VR video GoPro plans to
build and sell a jump ready 360-degree
camera array YouTube will support jump
so if you want to experience VR video
all you need is the YouTube app your
smartphone and some cardboard thank you
so much for joining us good luck and see
you next year